the folks so today I'm going to show you
how to tie a Windsor knot learn this in
1984 from a gentleman named the Egyptian
magician and is the most valuable thing
I took away from high school
it is usually hit or miss when you tie a
tie in the following fashion you can do
it perfectly every time this is how you
do it so first you take the tail in so
to speak I like to line it up with
roughly the second button that's visible
from the bottom then we're going to do
it's over the top you loop around the
same side and you make it very tight
like that this is going to form the
brace of one side then you go around the
opposite side through and you can see
I'm forming a V that's the framework for
the knot of the time and I make that
very tight and I want to make sure that
the tops of both of these points are
roughly the same height then I come
around I go through this is just like
you would normally tie a tie and then
you go through now you notice a few
things here so there's a framework you
can see that when I tighten it it makes
a perfect inverted triangle then all I
have to do is pinch in the inside and I
can modify pull out the top and then
pull to fit and you can see that has the
perfect length right about to belt level
and you flip it over and you have the
perfect tie